[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les achats
joué au début je suis le mec qui
adoptent le plus a tenu en fonction de
la tuque web services et j'adorais la
coiffure est magnifique dirait
l'algérino déjà belle emma bell c'est un
monsois algérie où
j'ai un petit souci dans la capitale oui
oui il était coiffé par gilbert montagné
les soucis à la fois que je sais bien
entendu non non c'est mal mais n'en
sais rien c'est rien messieux même si
une pelade les experts capillaire je
sais c'est une place un peu le propos
ben oui mais
tous les week-ends à illats et
bout sinon ça serait sûrement un peu de
un peu de un peu de stress mais c'est le
stress non n'entendait pas de ferme bien
oui vraiment je suis stressé parce
qu'ils ont fourni une bonne chronique
toute la semaine pour lâcher la balle
l'avait
commencée j'aime être au contact du
public
par semaine test rat 5,3 au bureau que
ça je suis avec mon bureau des rites
cela vous écris mon bureau avec dennis
ruy doigts
[Rires]
c'est d'ailleurs une question que je me
pose depuis longtemps ils ont commencé
locaux
[Rires]
combien de temps par semaine vous passez
au bureau mais ça je suis capable oui
cette semaine j'étais je me sentais pas
santé paltrow cupra r je ne sentais pas
[Musique]
ça fait longtemps vous le sentez pas non
ça fait longtemps vous le sentez parfois
c'est important de passer quand même aux
téléspectateurs passé quand même au
moins 15 minutes au bureau
ça remet tout le monde d'équerré voilà
et je sais très bien que quand je
reviendrai pas besoin oui vous avez dit
et chouf commandes et ils ont des choux
format je m'en dire que j'arrive au
bureau
c'est vrai
et là il ya des gags quand j'arrive tout
comme par hasard ils sont tous
automatiques ont travaillé sur les
barbus ya pas besoin vous arrivez avec
une escorte les flics les sirènes et
gyrophares donc on arrivé là
c'est quoi tu vas partir
[Rires]
comme chaque semaine on commence avec
toutes les petites séquences à picorer
tout ce que les téléspectateurs ont pu
rater au loup
de paix et on commence cette semaine
avec bernard montiel qui complètement
fait pas de doute que si tu vends tes
culottes salle voilà la vérité
mademoiselle
[Applaudissements]
l'achète il faut bien qu'ils ont
continué avec gilbert ds qui n'aime pas
quand on n'est pas d'accord avec lui
mais ne peut non plus quand on est
d'accord avec lui brûlé au loup en fait
là ces cas là les montagnes russes dans
les parcs d'attraction
je suis pour quoi ça n'a rien à voir
le président de chârost est de retour
quelques murs une question pour le
racing et son apport technique on parle
des réseaux sociaux c'est un secteur qui
en pleine mutation notamment en termes
de droit est ce que vous pouvez me
lâcher votre snap
[Rires]
signe
un film érotique à phoenix c'est parce
qu a pas de pénétration oui merci
vous connaissez les taux passion de baba
culture et oseille vous savez moi j'ai
été voir la maison de jean cocteau ça et
jean cocteau j'en
vois une maison a été visitée avant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon autant pour moi c'est l'oseille et
aux avait finalement qu'à ta maman un
truc
ses dix balles
d'après danse avec les stars découvrez
danse avec les routards et matthieu
delormeau la chose l'ip
[Applaudissements]
à
était ce un mois des pailles news
minutes non c'est normal c'est pas ça
fait appel si jamais nous regarde y'a
pas du tout rire d'avoir de news de vous
parce que vous avez vu non pas du tout
vous avez des lieux de candice pascal
vous là ça devrait pas tarder à la
tex et moi c'est raymond je suis en
émission j'aimerais bien de parler ah
ouais ah oui assez de regarder ce cas
pas aux comptes pour un psychopathe ce
que vous la connaissiez très peu quand
même non j'ai fait une belle accroche ça
veut dire comment il a fait pour moi mon
numéro est intrigué mais s'il avait dîné
avec tu vas être plus vivant que là que
tu nous parler d'elle sinon
à la basse pas sûr
on dirait on dirait qu'il a fait un
petit accident vasculaire
[Rires]
il est pas mal et comme ça tu vois
me cherche oui au génial accident c'est
vraiment il a été touché au canada mais
vraiment il ya eu un truc voilà et on
arrive quand on a un flash comme ça ils
étaient encore les yeux dans la nuit
d'hier qui étaient en plateau les femmes
aiment les hommes sur deux qui l'agacent
quelque chose de là tu dégages
passé 5 heures du matin jusqu'à 23
heures moi je suis un peu fatigué le
week-end en dîner le week-end je bondis
alors je vous direz vous pour parité
dollar fragilité de l'homme n'a aucune
femme qui aime la fragilité nord je vous
le dis avec sa foire est
joliment les fêlures la sensive
adore passer règne ben willey beaucoup
de ténors beaucoup de succès oui oui
vous avez deviné du sable
oui hier quand est ce parce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle a pas eu un peu un petit
flash envers vous plus tôt
une double situation mais moi il me
semble il ya quelque chose de plus
palpable qu'il y voilà quelque chose
j'ai été impressionné par votre manière
de danser
vraiment fait quelque chose de la vérité
je vous dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je pense qu'elle est vraiment un
vrai crush pour raymond ouais moi c'est
pas ça comme a dit raonic un crush
artistique c'est comme non mais c'est
vrai quand vous êtes danseur et que vous
voyez un danseur et oui au dessus de
vous vous renifler grec pour
esquisser personnel est ce que si je
l'envoie là je l'ambiance sur ça elle a
vu que j'étais voilà et même catégorie c
et pour elle c'est comme quand on te dit
je te rends compte fédérer ah oui à la
base c'était pareil c'est inquiète le
federer de la viande surgelée fédéral
oui quoi crs auraient alors où elle
rencontrait de famille
et toi c'est moi pas tu prends un truc
tu pourras chez savait qu'elle était pas
troublée elle était vraiment troublé par
mails entre deux équipes voient le real
madrid au psg
voilà mais l'attrait alors je dirais
[ __ ] et non à la bonne cuisine
j'ai dit la vérité pour moi le psg de la
danse c'est parce que en termes de
budget la raison je suis louhans
cuiseaux pas du tout non mais alors à
leur tonus à leurs journalistes s'en
fout total skema qui danse bien qu'il
aime et puis surtout je pense qu'elle
est je crois qu'elle est en plein chaos
qu'éthique je ne sais pas du tout mais
en tout cas ça me rappelait la
la moyenne des françaises c'est faux les
français vont en moyenne 1,5 fois
l'amour par semaine mais je pense qu'on
a des grosses surprises je serais
curieux de savoir que je posais des
questions autour data parmi les prennent
alors déjà castagne on sait que celle
27,5
lequel d'un coup je te plus je pense
qu'on aurait une vraie surpasser tout ça
m'a mis m'annoncer deux fois deux fois
par semaine c'est
la semaine mais je pense qu'on aurait
des vraies surprises avec en moyenne à
la fin du tome 3 dans ta tête la tête
entre deux dans ma tête j'ai un top 3
jeux wii
allez merci s'il vous plaît eux ils
appellent ça même
quand les matins mais vous à mon ami
sinon c'est pas moi non bon allez je
serais surpris ah oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu nous avait expliqué que sa libido est
en berne on
peut faire mieux abattant vous avez
malentendu il disait sa libido et étant
burnes
j'ai une vraie vie tout ça pour avoir la
chance de parler trop au bureau de faire
du ce mais la vraie question qu'on se
pose c'est delphine
non non les chiffres ça me gêne non je
parle est plein de choses mais j'aime
pas les chiffres c'est cool non les
trois thématiques se trouve à triel
médecine mais on va vers lui de briller
c'est vrai ça samedi par semaine deux
par semaine mais enfin ça dépend des
semaines mais déjà je suis pas là trois
jours par semaine oui
mais non sélectionné par jour sa défense
on part en vacances
c'est quoi une bonne semaine le beh non
une bonne semaine s'est plusieurs fois
par jour non non mais
non mais c'est vrai au combien de fois
rodez je tiens il écrié sportif j'ai vu
un intérêt de plus en plus à l'essai ne
voit pas pendant trois jours donc
forcément quand elle revient bah oui ça
lui chargé à roger haut allez succomber
merci réponse ça va tu écris nec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
après notre rencontre hier mon coeur
je pense vraiment eu en tout cas elle
est un coup de foudre amical pour aller
à san siro les chroniqueurs en show un
peu trop chaud et devrait peut-être un
peu plus ken cyril et c'est la raison
pour laquelle eh bien je vais contacter
une personne qui m'est cher pour tester
leur degré de chârost titude j'ai fait
appel à mon ex rubini kara qui a appelé
tous les chroniqueurs pour savoir s'il
était chaud de faire un petit resto
espèces ou si c'était chaud tout court
[Musique]
hello guillaume c ruby
coucou c'est à vue me cache a bien
ouais ça va super l'esprit grippe mais
peu après le bicloo nantais élodée m'ont
combattu et ses rubis deux manches pense
que là est actuellement en train de
livrer des khaled
kabbani
[Musique]
oui ça va je te dérange pas je pense
assez par quatre chemins je suis mon
passage à l'émission je fais que de
penser à toi vraiment j'aime ton look
j'aime ton flow j'aime ce que tu dégages
j'aime porter soleil ouais vraiment
j'ai pris l'émission
je fais plus de conseils 3 en fait
je suis à djouba sur les à me dérange
pas j'aime bien les hommes avec de
l'expérience tu vas tu as assez courtois
je t'aime bout et je sais que tu
change régulièrement de femme et moi ça
me dérange pas je peux être ta maîtresse
j'ai changé il faut passer depuis
émissions chimiques et de conseils toi
une jeune femme que j'apprécie même si
je suis pas d'accord avec beaucoup de
choses mais on pourrait en discuter au
lit tous sacrés t'es pas d'accord
jamais un débat qui capte la musique
chez pas mal de clarisse
métrologie pas moi je suis encore pions
moi je suis confrères
[Musique]
et moi je suis pas sage en faut car
cette honda
pour papa langues ouais après why notes
et on voit ce qu'on fait
et ce que ce soit était fait apprécier
ce que pas être du tout a dit c'est pour
toi
tu sais que je suis avec fatou demain
samedi à 14 h et 14 h 30
et 14 h 30 demain cette chaude au bien
manger comme ça
mais les coûts sont passés pacte c'était
ok pas cool j'aime tomber les
amigos times paru tempérer l'adresse
très bien le problème ok bisous bisous
et bien c'est vraiment des charges
et
lui mais c'est un chacal non mais quel
charme et linux et me battait reina
lyonnais c'est vrai mais depuis que vous
êtes célibataire
droite ici on travaille je suis pas toi
tu m'excite je dis tu es ce que tu vas
aller au mexique
[Applaudissements]
il y en a qui est mort c'est quand même
bien ce stade je suis courtois anonnce
nationale bref oui t'es pas courtois
l'endroit du rendez-vous des gones est
alors que tout coup de coin secondes
mais c'est ça un gros nez grosse bingham
oui oui bien sûr mais non kayani non
cette mort alors
on à la suisse s'excuse on peut parler
de compte
derrière ou pas non c'est assez mal
c'est leur honneur c'est regrettable
le gâteau si c'est pas son bureau c'est
pas ma faute ce qui les met aujourd'hui
aux sections mon bureau quand je ne
savais même pas bonjour c'est vrai il
reste qu'il va déballer dans ma tête
partout vous êtes dans l'ascenseur hier
matin on dit bonjour syrie
[Rires]
on a vu que benjamin castaldi et
guillaume genton c'était mal parti du
coup immobilier kara a bien proposé
debate au restaurant mais quelqu'un
sait-il pointé la réponse
rubis attend tranquille au resto et sa
petite coupe de champagne oui elle a eu
du mal à ton favorable mais alors qui
qui est un aimant txaro verdez castaldi
raymond
ses 10 ans et regardez bien comment on a
décidé de punir les chambres c'est
exceptionnel
[Musique]
g
toujours beaucoup d'idées
[Applaudissements]
chez les messieurs le jour
là dessus
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
la saisine au restaurant et c'est
lui-même qui est globale et qui est allé
lorraine c'est le patron qui lui même
n'est pas un sens qu'elle aime qu'à
lui-même début de saison merci nos
restaurants qu'on aime voilà
exceptionnel semaine et ben bravo
[Applaudissements]